there has however been speculation that
this report was going to reveal
either that russia had interfered in or
sought to influence the referendum
in the committee's view it's worse than
that the revolt
report reveals that no one in government
knew
if russia interfered in or sought to
influence the
referendum because they did not want to
know
the uk government have actively avoided
looking for
evidence that russia interfered we were
told that they hadn't seen any evidence
but that is meaningless if they hadn't
looked for it
the committee found it astonishing that
no one in government had sought
beforehand
to protect the referendum from such
attempts
or investigate it afterwards what
attempts to influence it
there may have been the government
the uk government should have recognized
the threat back in 2014
in relation to the scottish referendum
but it didn't
it didn't understand the threat until
after the hack and leak operation
against the democratic national
committee in the united states
and because it was too slow to recognize
the threat it didn't take action to
protect the uk
in 2016. one would have thought that
once the existence of that threat had
been understood
seeing what had happened in the us that
someone here would have wanted to
understand the extent and nature of the
threat to the uk
and we wanted to see the post-referendum
assessment
but there isn't one there has been no
assessment
of russian interference in the eu
referendum
and this goes back to nobody wanting to
touch this issue
with a 10-foot poll this is in stark
contrast
to the u.s response to reports of
interference
in the 2016 presidential elections
no matter how politically awkward or
potentially embarrassing
there should have been an assessment of
russian interference in the eu
referendum
and there must now be one and the public
must be told the results of that
assessment